herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
auf ihrem live stream zu aktuellen
diskussion und ereignissen
wenn wir uns die korona panini mal ja
als sturm vorstellen dann stellen wir
immer wieder fest wir sitzen alle
irgendwo zusammen in einem boot aber die
einen sitzen ja in der ersten klasse
haben es zumindest einigermaßen bequem
und eine ganze menge leute sitzen eher
unten in der holzklasse mit schlechtem
wlan mit wenig platz zusammengedrängt
und häufig auch noch nicht mal geld für
warmes essen
wir wollen daher heute mal auf diese
menschen gucken und besonders auf die
kinder und jugendlichen die davon
betroffen sind die eben auch nicht so
privilegierten verhältnissen kommen und
oder diese diesen bock dauern daher noch
mal besonders leiden und das bild
gleicht versprechen mit dem gründer der
berliner arche bernd siggelkow fragen
und kommentare dazu wie immer sehr gerne
in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder per e mail an zdf
heute.de zdf.de hier ist es eingeblendet
und dann krieg ich das hier auch mein
rechner von der redaktion gedrückt bevor
wir aber gleich mit herrn segelte über
das große problem sprechen und über die
frage was kann man da eigentlich tun was
brauchen diese kinder hat mein kollege
pablo salahi mal ein paar stimmen der
betroffenen zusammengeschnitten arbeiten
auf hochtouren schulen auch die kinder
vom zu hause die eltern sind wir sind
machtlos 51 euro peter schlecht da kann
ich dass es immerhin besser als nix aber
ist es fast genauso wie nichts es ist
nicht mal ein tropfen auf dem heißen
stein und ich glaube familien die in
einer finanziell deutlich prekären
situation leben betrifft das noch sehr
sehr viel härter ja also schwierige
zeiten gerade für menschen die es eh
schon schwer haben darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit bern segelteam gründer der
berliner arche hallo ich bin dass wir
uns zeit haben guten abend sind das
stimmen die ihnen bekannt vorkommen
herzige co ja das stimmt zum teil stimme
die mir bekannt vorkommen
viele menschen ja jetzt gerade in
situationen sind die nicht absehbar sind
es ist kein licht am ende des tunnels zu
erkennen und viele menschen besitzen
seit elf monaten auf heißen kohlen und
wissen nicht wie es weitergehen soll
wie hat das denn jetzt ihre arbeit
geprägten letzten elf monaten was hat
sich da verändert
wir haben am 16 märz als der lok gallus
gegenüber nacht unser programm komplett
umgestellt die kinder konnten ja nicht
mehr die asse gekommen wir sind dann zu
ihnen nach hause gegangen haben
innerhalb von einer woche 1630 familien
deutschlandweit besucht und ihn
regelmäßig lebensmittel gebracht
wir haben über nacht eine virtuelle
arche aufgebaut in dem wir mit den
kindern hausaufgaben machen
homeschooling sie unterstützen mit den
wenigen technischen mitteln die sie zur
verfügung haben wir haben hunderte von
smartphones besorgt laptops und tablets
damit sie überhaupt amrums koling
teilnehmen können
wir machen mittlerweile auch livestreams
und am nachmittag bei den familien zu
hause zu sein die nicht mehr in die
arche kommen können aber je länger der
blogger und diese ganze situation anhält
umso schwieriger wird auch unsere arbeit
wir machen eigentlich nur noch
schadensbegrenzung
bevor wir dann noch tiefer eintauchen
möchte mir noch mal ganz kurz ihre
arbeit vorstellen die sie damit der
arche leisten
da hat meine kollegin annika schultz mal
eine kurze vorstellung zusammengebastelt
seid ganz siggelkow die arche 1995
gegründet hat wird dort benachteiligten
kindern geholfen durch corona hat sich
auch die arbeit der arche verändert ein
ziel lücken schließen die
schulschließungen hinterlassen
digital helfen siggelkow und sein team
wo eltern und schulen ist nicht schaffen
erklären etwa lernstoff über videos
kindern den zu hause die technik fürs
homeschooling oder schlichtweg die ruhe
fehlt bekommen das vor ort geboten
auch in grundlegenden bereichen werden
familien in not unterstützt etwa durch
lebensmittel oder ein warmes essen für
die kinder
für sie ist die arche ein zufluchtsort
und eine stütze in dieser schwierigen
zeit
sie haben gerade gesagt der segel kohl
im ersten block dann haben sie komplett
dichtmachen können das hat sich jetzt
ein bisschen geändert oder na ja
geändert ist eine seite in berlin haben
wir dürfen wir noch pro gruppe fünf
kinder haben die kleinen kinder also die
kita kinder dürfen alle kommen
beziehungsweise auch
mit notbetreuung wir haben ja sehr
verhaltensauffällige kinder und deswegen
dürfe nicht klein kommen
aber es ist halt wenn sie einen
tagesbesuch von 200 bis 350 kinder jeden
tag haben denn kann im moment maximal
alle zehn tagen jedes kind kommen
was hat das für auswirkungen auf die
kinder was beobachten sie da ja die
kinder sind ja zu hause zusammen gefährt
auf engsten raum will ich das so nennen
darf sie gehen ja eigentlich nicht mehr
raus sie haben keine schule
wir haben familien die wohnen auf 70
quadratmeter mit sechs personen die
haben drei geschwister vier geschwister
mittlerweile darf er nur noch einer
eingeladen werden dann ist das für die
anderen kinder ungerecht weil jetzt
gerade bruder oder schwester jemand
einladen dürfen dann führt das sehr
schnell zu aggressionen wir haben schon
situationen gehabt für die kinder
aufeinander losgegangen sind auf ihre
eltern los gegangen sind
wir haben das problem dass viele kinder
zu hause jetzt nur vom rechner sitzen
und nur noch am pc zocken die spiele
sind ja auch so ausgerichtet dass immer
mehr
ja wenn diese suchtfaktor verein ist es
bei vielen kindern nach dem ersten
locker und hatten wir etwa kinder die so
zehn bis zwanzig kilo zugenommen haben
es ist bewegungsmangel da ist das
falsche ernährung da ist es nicht genug
geld bei den familien zu hause um sich
auch zu ernähren vor allem gesund zu
ernähren und da müssen wir dann hin
das haben sie gerade schon ein paar
maßnahmen gesagt was sie versuchen zu
tun aber was kann man jetzt konkret
machen also wenn wir mal anfangen zum
beispiel bei dem problem bewegungsmangel
wie versuchen sie dagegen vorzugehen
wir machen läuft stehen in dem wir
wettkämpfe mit den familien machen über
youtube haben wir so einen kanal und
schicken jeden tag einen link oben da
machen wir wettkämpfe und dann geben wir
ihn manchmal so tages oder wochen
challenges wo sie verschiedene machen
sachen machen sollen zum beispiel auf
den spielplatz gehen sich selber filmen
wie sie ein paar rollen an der klimmzug
stange machen oder ja wir müssen da ganz
kreativ sein wir haben nach dem ersten
locker und alle unsere fahrräder inliner
roller verteilt wir hatten nach dem
essen noch gar nichts mehr in der arche
weil wir wollten dass die kinder raus
gehen und sich beschäftigen und das hält
heute noch an wir müssen sehr kreativ
sein wie wir die kinder zur bewegung
bringen und von zu hause weg bekommen
wie schaffen sie das denn dass die
kinder überhaupt einer stange bleiben
das klingt ja dann auch so dass da muss
dann auch ja wieder jemand sein zuhause
der auch sagt guck doch mal auf den
youtube kanal guck doch mal was
er segelte was die arche gemacht hat
klappt das
das brauchen wir eigentlich nicht die
eltern sind in der regel nicht die
motivation wir haben ja alle
telefonnummern der kinder also über
whatsapp sind miteinander verbunden wir
haben gruppen wo wir diesen link immer
wieder streuen
unsere mitarbeiter machen ja jeden tag
mit den kindern auch hausaufgaben auch
virtuell da sind sie sowieso mit ihnen
an der strippe und die kinder haben und
auch die eltern die möglichkeit uns 24
stunden am tag und in der nacht
anzurufen wenn es denn tatsächlich
brennt also wir haben nicht das problem
dass diese programme nicht gesehen
werden
wir müssen natürlich motivieren aber wir
sind ja eben auch mindestens einmal in
der woche an der tür klingeln
unterstützen mit lebensmittel und
versuchen noch moralisch aufzubauen
das heißt da können sie sagen ihn ist
keiner verloren gegangen oder gibt es
dann tatsächlich dann doch auch
kollateralschaden
ich würde eher sagen wir haben durch
dadurch dass wir vom ersten tag an für
unsere familien da waren und dadurch
auch in die medien präsent waren haben
wir eher noch mehr gewonnen wir hatten
nach den sommerferien allein in unserer
haupt einrichtungen 150 neue kinder die
sich bei uns angemeldet haben die jetzt
auch noch zu denen dazu kommen ich will
nicht sagen dass wir den ein oder
anderen nicht verloren haben den kontakt
haben wir nicht verloren aber sie sind
nicht mehr regelmäßig dabei das sind
aber zumindest ja etwas ermutigende
nachrichten dass es nicht alles verloren
ist man muss halt nur genug tun wenn ich
ihre worte da richtig deute aber was sie
gerade gesagt haben dass es den menschen
schlecht geht auch schlechter geht das
sind auch zahlen die sich bestätigen
lassen also dass das nicht nur ein
gefühl mein kollege pablo sie dalla hier
hat man also ein paar fakten für uns
zusammen getragen im ersten halbjahr
2020 verzeichnete die gewalt ambulanz
der berliner charité 23 prozent mehr
fälle von gewalt an kindern
außerdem gab es im vergangenen jahr 31
prozent mehr online beratungen beim
kinder- und jugendtelefon der nummer
gegen kummer um familien in der korona
krise zu unterstützen soll es in diesem
jahr erneut einen kinderbonus geben in
höhe von einmalig 150 euro pro kind
tja die bundesregierung hat genau darf
beschlossen menschen mit die die
grundsicherung beziehen mehr zu
unterstützen ich kann mal kurz auf den
täter zu aufrufen
den habe ich hier auf den rechner gelegt
wenn er jetzt mal sich kurz aufbaut
anblick kollegen mal lieber bitte man
auch mein rechner schalten hier
das ist vom bundesministerium für arbeit
und soziales ein tweet von gestern vom 4
februar
wir sehen die zusätzlichen corona
belastungen für menschen in der
grundsicherung deshalb hat der
koalitionsausschuss gestern den corona
zuschlag und einen erneuten
anrechnungsfrei ein kinderbonus
vereinbart
alle aktuellen maßnahmen für die
grundsicherung in unserer übersicht zu
sehen wir jetzt hier also es gibt 150
euro corona zuschlag für erwachsene 150
euro kinderbonus pro kind es gibt
kostenlose ffp zwei masken
kostenübernahme für digitale endgeräte
für distanz unterricht also tablets zum
beispiel oder laptops und einen
erleichterten zugang zur grundsicherung
des ende des jahres und wir hätten
darüber auch gerne gesprochen mit der
berliner senatorin schere ist die
verantwortlich ist für bildung jugend
und familie
die haben wir nicht erreicht sie hat nur
einen tweet abgesetzt oder ihr senat als
das gestern getan da schreibt sie wir
müssen der pandemie und auch in zukunft
sicherstellen dass alle schülerinnen und
schüler an digitalen lernangeboten
teilhaben können deswegen freue ich mich
sehr dass die jobcenter nun digitale
endgeräte für bedürftige schülerinnen
und schüler finanzieren so also es wird
ein bisschen was getan hätte geld reicht
das es ist der ton gerade weg ich kann
sie nicht mehr hören
also ich bin immer noch online okay
jetzt jetzt geht ist natürlich eine
wirkliche zu sagen ja es gibt diese
endgeräte die sollen in die familien
kombi sollen vom jobcenter finanziell
die frage ist letztendlich wäre schließt
diese endgeräte bei den familien zu
hause an die unter umständen gar nicht
in der lage sind das zu tun
das ist auch nichts neues denn die
bundesregierung hat bereits 2020 das
digital paket verabschiedet und gesagt
dass jedes kind ein zugang zu einem
digitalen endgeräte haben soll das ist
bis heute nicht passiert und ich glaube
aber auch dass es jetzt ein versprechen
bleibt die menschen wenn jetzt alles im
jobcenter und beantragen ihre endgeräte
aber es ist nicht in letzter instanz
durch gedacht wer installiert die
software
wer erklärt den kindern wie es
funktionieren soll wenn sie denn im lok
tor doch zu hause sind also die zusage
ist gut die maßnahme ist perfekt aber
sie muss eben noch umgesetzt werden und
ich glaube dass er mich so richtig dran
es gab ja auch vor einigen wochen bei
einer dieser vielen bund länder
konferenz die zusage dass es spezielle
tarife geben soll für junge menschen ich
habe hier einen einen kommentar auf
facebook von claudia grau die schreibt
schon vor corinna war es so dass das
jobcenter für kinder die laptops
benötigt haben nicht die kosten
übernommen hat meiner meinung nach
müssen alle kinder mit der nötigen
technik ausgestattet werden das soll
jetzt kommen die frage ist ob das so
passiert aber dann kommt ihr kommentar
noch weiter ebenso schüler tarife für
kinder so dass immer ein wechsel
zwischen lernen auf papier als auch mit
technologie möglich ist aber haben sie
was gehört von diesem schüler tarifen
oder von diesen vergünstigten jugend
tarifen das ist irgendwie untergang habe
ich das gefühl
naja ich habe nicht davon gehört immer
noch ist deutschland ein
entwicklungsland was das thema internet
betrifft wir haben teilweise in berlin
gebiete wo man gar kein netz hat das
müsste auch ausgebaut werden dann hat
man das problem auch die lern software
auf den viele kinder auf einmal
zurückgreifen und stürzt dauernd ab dass
die zu hause wenn das wlan nicht so
funktioniert man hat 34 kinder die
machen zur gleichen zeit hausaufgaben
und wenn sie tatsächlich den endgeräte
haben ist die frage ob die leitungen die
zu hause ist die sie haben sie müssen
erstmal eine größere leitung bekommen
damit sie mit so vielen geräten im
internet sein können müsste vergrößert
werden dann verrät bestimmte tarife ist
das eine aber die umsetzung das dann bei
den anbietern zu erfragen zu sagen ich
brauche jetzt eine schnellere leitung
das dauert auch bis zu zwei monate und
ich frage mich wie das alles
funktionieren soll
die bundeskanzlerin hat ja vor zwei
tagen eine bürgersprechstunde abgehalten
auch digital weil das ja alles anders
nicht geht und da wurde auch das problem
fernunterricht angesprochen oder
generell das problem schule und sie hat
dazu folgendes gesagt
homeschooling nicht funktioniert oder
wenn man da nicht mit kommt dann ist das
schon extrem schwer deshalb kann ich
auch nur noch mal das wiederholen was er
gesagt haben wir wollen ja auch die
schulen als erstes wieder aufmachen
damit da auch was passiert man muss ja
auch sagen dass auch unsere
digitalisierung noch nicht so gut
fortgeschritten ist wie man es
eigentlich sein sollte ich glaube da
gibt es jetzt einen richtigen schub
ja da gibt es zum shoot die frage ist
nur reicht das herzige co naja die
menschen und nicht nur unsere menschen
mit denen wir zu tun haben gehen schon
auf dem zahnfleisch denn es ist ja fakt
dass die kinder nicht hausaufgaben
machen sondern dass der lehrer nach
hause die aufgaben gibt die er
eigentlich den kindern weitergeben
sollte damit sind jetzt die eltern
beauftragt die sind natürlich an ihrer
kapazitätsgrenze die menschen die arbeit
gehen müssen ihre arbeit reduzieren
damit sie auf die vier und stunden mit
ihren kindern diese aufgaben erledigen
können die menschen mit denen wir zu tun
haben haben häufig ein sprachliches
problem oder auch ein bildungsproblem da
geht es nicht voran
und da hat man es monatelang versagt von
den kultusministern da hat keiner sich
bewegt und wir wissen ist schon ewig
wussten wir schon foto und wir wissen
auch es auch heute
die frage ist warum man nicht besser
reagiert und schneller und wenn wir
wissen dass es nicht so ist dann wissen
wir auch dass wenn die kinder wieder in
die schule kommen dann haben sie
erhebliche bildungslücken und die werden
durch das system nicht ausgeglichen weil
man kann die kinder jetzt nicht alle die
klasse wiederholen das interne stehen so
viele kinder vor der tür
die jetzt in die schule kommen wir haben
gar nicht genug lehrer und deswegen
fordere ich eigentlich dass man alle
lehramtsstudenten zusammenzieht zur
unterstützung der lehrer und das
homeschooling und dann muss man sich
noch mal genau hinschauen welche
fachkräfte gibt es noch die die kinder
unterstützen können
die dame die wir gerade gesehen haben da
im gespräch mit bundeskanzlerin merkel
die wir auch im ersten zusammenschnitt
schon hatten die ihr sehr emotional war
weil sie so verzweifelt weil die hat
auch davon berichtet dass die eltern
häufig völlig überfordert sind entweder
weil sie selber die sagten
bildungsprobleme haben teilweise gar
nicht richtig lesen und schreiben können
den kindern deswegen nicht helfen können
haben sie da auch unterstützungsangebote
für die eltern oder was kann man für
diese eltern dann tun
naja das ist das was sich letztendlich
oder wenn wir mehr menschen an den
schulen haben zur unterstützung der
lehrer weil der lehrer kann ja nicht die
eierlegende wollmilchsau sein und er ist
ja in deutschland auch alleine vor
vielen kindern wenn er auch nur im
ballungsgebiet arbeitet hat er das
problem er hat ja auch noch diese vielen
verhaltens kreativen kinder und da
braucht der lehrer unterstützung und wir
unterstützen natürlich in dem sinne dass
die eltern uns anrufen nur der kinder
ihre hausaufgaben fotografieren mit dem
handy wir legen die uns auf den
bildschirm und dann telefonieren wir mit
den kindern eins zu eins via facetime
und machen dann die hausaufgaben
beziehungsweise die lehraufgaben und die
eltern sind natürlich sehr froh dass wir
dieses angebot haben und die die es
nicht können die holen wir dann
teilweise die arche sofern das denn
möglich ist aber was gebraucht wird ist
ein schlechten deckungssystem und das
können wir auch nicht anbieten weil wir
dann im vergleich zu den vielen kindern
die zur schule gehen nur eine kleine
einrichtung sind sie haben gerade
angesprochen dass es ja die
möglichkeiten gibt also in die schule
weiterhin zu gehen es gibt ja die
notbetreuung auch wenn die
präsenzpflicht ausgesetzt ist und
bundesfamilienminister denn gefeiert
dazu diese woche folgendes gesagt
die leitlinie das eben auch in den
schulen ja nicht eine komplette
schließung erfolg sondern die aussetzung
der präsenzpflicht und die möglichkeit
der notbetreuung und gerade bei den
kindern die jetzt große schwierigkeiten
haben dort nicht hinterherzukommen oder
wo es sogar vom von seiten des
jugendamtes eine empfehlung gibt dass
dieses kind in die notbetreuung gehen
sollte weil es zu hause nicht
ausreichend betreut werden kann oder
weil eben die entsprechende
unterstützung des mit kommen im
unterricht nicht gewährleistet ist dort
soll die notbetreuung ermöglicht werden
ja das heißt aber auch dass die eltern
dann ja auch die kinder schicken müssen
klappt das in der praxis also ich kenne
kaum eltern die das machen und ich kenne
kaum kinder die diese notbetreuung gehen
sie müssen sich vorstellen jetzt musste
lehrer noch ein viel größeres spagat
machen das ist ähnlich wie bei uns er
hat dann unter umständen eine handvoll
kinder vielleicht auch nur drei oder
vier
die muss ja unterrichten aber er muss
letztendlich auch dafür da sein dass die
anderen kinder zu hause weiter kommen
dann machte entweder 1 ergibt dann
irgend welchen stoff nach hause oder
ergibt digital ein was die kinder machen
und das ist ja die große herausforderung
die lehrer müssen eigentlich ansprechbar
sein für die eltern und für die familie
und für die kinder muss theoretisch ein
bis zweimal in der woche bei den kindern
zu hause anrufen das kann er nicht oder
kann es natürlich noch viel weniger
wenn ihr diesen spagat schaffen muss
zwischen zwei drei kindern in der not
betreuung und 23 24 kinder zu hause
das heißt ja dann aber auch wie sie
sagten die eltern schicken ihre kinder
nicht dass das ist vielleicht auch
besonders die eltern nicht machen wo es
die kinder besonders nötig hätten ich
sag mal sprichwort kindeswohl gefährt
und so dass erfahrungen die sie machen
wenn eine kindeswohlgefährdung vorliegt
dann kümmert sich die in der kinder die
eltern in der regel ja sowieso nicht
also ich glaube das ist schon gedacht
die schwieriger punkt aber was ich eben
an erfahrung gesammelt dass das unsere
kinder und unsere familien die gebeutelt
sind die immer schwierigkeiten haben
haben sowieso ängste und die haben auch
unglaublich angst vor corona und sie
schicken schon ihre kinder aus dem grund
nicht in die schule weil sie sich dort
anstecken können weil das was sie im
fernsehen sehen und auch von der
regierung hören ist dass wir die
pandemie einschränken müssen deswegen
sind die menschen zu hause wenn sie dann
allerdings ihre kinder raus schicken ihn
nicht schulen dann wissen sie von
vornherein ist das ansteckungsrisiko
großer und wir können sie nicht
verurteilen dass es nicht tun und ihre
kinder auch wenn sie die
verhaltenstherapie iv oder lernbehindert
sind so wie man das in berlin manchmal
sagt oder nicht so gut lernen und auf in
der auffassungsgabe haben oder sie
können was der bildungsfernen schicht
dann werden sich auf den oft in eine
schublade gesteckt aber das sind die
ängste die die menschen haben sie wollen
dann eben auch nicht rausgehen weil das
risiko ist einfach zu groß meine frau
ist in hamburg sonderpädagogin und die
hat gerade das problem hat sie mir
berichtet dass sie quasi kinder wo sie
das gefühl hat sie müssten jetzt
eigentlich eine notbetreuung kommen eben
weil sie ihn nennt leiten weil die
eltern sich nicht kümmern oder weil es
halt wichtig ist dass der soziale
kontakt auch zu den lehrkräften da ist
sie quasi nicht mehr in die schule holen
kann weil die präsenzpflicht ausgesetzt
ist kennen sie dieses problem auch aus
berlin ja natürlich das problem ist
einfach dass die ansprechpartner nicht
nach hause gehen und die menschen nicht
kontaktieren wenn ich doch weiß da ist
ein kind das ist im kindeswohl gefährdet
oder dies in einer familie wo es nicht
so gut funktioniert dann sollte doch der
sozialarbeiter oder der
mit dem betreuer an die tür gehen
klingeln fragen wo kann ich dich
unterstützen dass man das jetzt nicht
das passiert in der regel nicht weil wir
haben beim ersten locker und
festgestellt das hilfesystem ist mir
komplett runtergefahren worden man
steckt den kopf in den sand manche
jugendämter haben nicht mal mehr
beratungsangebote
man hat da nur noch dieser telefone die
man anrufen kann wenn man wirklich ein
problem hat aber die probleme sind ja zu
hause die sind ja häufig noch unter der
bettdecke gestellt und nur die lehrer
die wirklich zeit haben oder wie man
sich sagen zeit habe sondern die
wirklich sich kümmern
die sind auch ganz nah beim kind dran
dann gibt es natürlich ganz viele derer
die wollen sind ihre hände sind aber
gebunden weil sie die kraft nicht haben
nicht genug unterstützung haben und da
gibt es wahrscheinlich auch lehrer die
das nichts zu tun aber das will ich
nicht verurteilen sondern ich glaube
auch lehrer erzieher in den kitas haben
natürlich auch das problem sie setzte
sich jeden tag einem erheblichen risiko
aus auch meine mitarbeiter weil sie eben
mit kindern arbeiten die auch eine
ansteckung an sie weitergeben könnten
das heißt wenn wir jetzt konstruktiv
fragen was brauchen diese kinder was
brauchen die familien jetzt in dieser
zeit hieße das eigentlich wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe jugendämter
beratungseinrichtungen müssen wieder
rausgehen können müssen wieder in die
familien gehen können und dort nachsehen
wie es den kindern geht also verein
brauchen sie eine transparenz ich glaube
dass die jugend ist sowieso ein bisschen
an ihrem image arbeiten müssen weil die
die menschen mit dem wir zu tun haben
wir mehr chronisch angst vor dem
jugendamt und wenn man da eine
imagekampagne machen würde könnte sich
das vielleicht verändern aber man müsste
auch eine transparenz haben wo
organisation gerade das jugendamt und
das system noch mal nach außen zeigt
hier da ist unsere präsenz wir sind da
wir haben zeit für euch wir kümmern uns
um euch aber das ist ja wie so ähnlich
wie bei der nummer gegen kummer oder
viele anderer theologe sorgentelefon man
die sind nur erreichbar wenn man geld
auf dem handy hat und unsere familien
haben in der regel kein geld und wir
sind per boot zu erreichen was ja keine
andere organisation ist deswegen die
zahlen die sie eben veröffentlicht haben
die sind gut aber die dunkelziffer die
ist noch viel größer und die werden wir
erst feststellen wenn die kinder wieder
in die schule gehen und wenn die
sozialkontakte da sind die solche sachen
feststellen ich habe jetzt ein paar
fragen aus unserer zuschauerschaft zum
beispiel von sarah kock sie möchte
wissen was tut die politik auf
verschiedenen ebenen um
diese jungen menschen und einrichtungen
wie ihre arche zu unterstützen
und was können wir direkt in der
gesellschaft tun damit den betroffenen
und den jungen leuten und familien
geholfen das war bei der politik an also
was tut die politik um sie zu
unterstützen in ihrer arbeit in unserer
arbeit überhaupt nichts weil wir leben
seit vielen jahren nur von spenden wir
versuchen unsere einrichtung so gut wie
möglich aufrecht zu erhalten deswegen
brauchen eine breite
öffentlichkeitsarbeit
die politik hat in meiner wahrnehmung
sehr wenig getan neben letzten elf
monaten außer das land bremen hat
hunderttausend ipads an die schüler
verteilt und die arbeiten heute schon
damit die sind auch eingerichtet das
haben die meisten bundesländer versäumt
und dieser schnellschuss jetzt mit den
einmal hilfen und auch mit dem
möglichkeiten an ein digitales endgerät
zu kommen sind meiner meinung nach
irgendwie auch nur dinge um löcher zu
stopfen und menschen zu beruhigen ich
glaube es erst wenn es da ist und
deswegen bin ich ein bisschen politisch
verdrossen muss ich sagen was das thema
kinder gibt betrifft denn sie stehen
nicht in der mitte der gesellschaft
sondern sie sind die abgehängte
generation
sie sind ja in berlin das heißt sie
werden die berliner senatorin sein also
frau scheeres kennen was sagt ihr denn
ihnen wenn sie damit mit ihren problemen
hinkommen naja erstmal habe ich gar
keine zeit zu ihr hin zu kommen sie wird
mich wahrscheinlich in den medien
wahrnehmen
elf monate lang hat kein politiker sich
in dem sinne bei uns gemeldet und hat
gesagt ja sie haben recht oder nein sie
haben recht ich habe auch nichts dagegen
wenn man mit mir konstruktiv diskutiert
und lösung erarbeiten möchte dass es bis
heute nicht passiert wenn ich glaube das
liegt einfach so ein bisschen an der
ohnmacht die die politischen instanzen
gerade haben denn nach dem ersten locker
und hat man gedacht okay es wird jetzt
alles besser und hatte nicht damit
gerechnet dass es eher noch schlimmer
wird und jetzt in dieser dunklen
jahreszeit dass die menschen viel
resignierter sind als noch im frühjahr
2020 ich schon noch mal hier bei uns in
die kommentare da gibt es so
verschiedene stimmen also einmal auch
die frage die ich glaube ich jetzt nicht
wirklich beantworten kann die aber doch
einige beschäftigt
das ist mit ketten familien mit zwei
kindern oder mehreren die keine
unterstützung vom jobcenter sondern nur
kinderzuschlag bekommen bekommen sie
auch ein laptop finanziert das ist eine
schwierige frage ich vermute mal segelt
darauf haben sie auch keine antwort also
wir haben ja in
elf monaten an 600 kinder laptops und
tablets verteilt damit sie überhaupt
voran kommen aber ich glaube dass man da
sich an die schule wenden sollte sagen
meine kinder können nicht daran
teilnehmen und es darf ja kein kind die
bildung verwehrt werden deswegen muss
niemand sei schule oder politische
instanz das sollen die eltern einfach
auch mal wenn sie da nicht leute kommen
unsere politiker anschreiben denn je
mehr menschen etwas tun und abfragen
desto mehr wird sich hoffentlich bewegen
wenn es nur einzelne sind wird nicht
viel passieren
hier gibt es einen kommentar von
armageddon auf youtube der schreibt wir
würden ich würde mal sagen wenn das so
weitergeht brauchen die kinder
psychiater und psychologen ist es nicht
schon jetzt schon längst der fall dass
das bringt notwendig wäre und wenn ja
gibt es behandlungen und
behandlungsmöglichkeiten
also natürlich wissen wir dass die
psychologen haben hochkonjunktur die
sind sicherlich auch an einem rand ihrer
möglichkeiten die kommen und wir werden
immer mehr probleme feststellen weil im
moment ist noch alles hinter
vorgehaltener hand hinter verschlossenen
türen und wir sehen viele dinge nicht
wir selber haben nach dem ersten block
tor und schon drei oder vier mal alleine
in berlin
das jugendamt einschalten müssen weil
uns starke probleme aufgefallen sind wir
haben zugesehen wie es in anderen
städten nach kindes in suzuka ich glaube
das wird noch mal eine ganze schippe
schwieriger werden wenn die kinder
wieder zur schule gehen und sehen wie
sie tatsächlich abgehängt sind weil sie
eben nicht so gefördert worden sind wie
die bildungsnahen schichten oder wie die
akademiker kinder oder vielleicht auch
die lehrer die kinder von pädagogen
das sehen wir noch nicht ab aber ich
glaube wenn kinder merken dass sie
verlierer sind in einem system das mit
ellbogen kämpft dann werden wir noch
viele kinder beim psychiater psychologen
haben denn sie überhaupt den platz
gekommen und wenn es jemanden gibt der
ihnen das eher möglich dahin zu gehen da
gibt es ja auch häufig große
hemmschwellen oder ja natürlich möchte
keiner zugeben dass er ein problem hat
und verhaltensauffälligkeit
verhaltensauffälligkeiten zeigen sich
dann in gewalt in aggressionen oder
einen anderen dingen oder auch in der
schule wenn man nicht mehr aufpasst ich
glaube das große problem wird erstens
sein wenn die schule wieder losgeht
werden viele kinder
pünktlich zum unterricht kommen weil sie
mittlerweile eine ganz andere tages zur
nacht struktur haben das führt dazu dass
sie weniger schlaf haben führt natürlich
dann auch zu körperlichen und
psychischen problemen und dann gibt es
natürlich nicht die vielen psychiater
und psychologen oder die ausgrenzung
dass kinder eben wenn sie zugeben müssen
ich habe jetzt ein problem sie wollen ja
auch in der schule nicht gemobbt werden
das haben wir auch ganz häufig das
problem dass viele kinder denn eine
rolle spielen oder vieles kaschieren
indem sie eben auch ihre probleme
überspielen
jetzt habe ich gerade die frage bisschen
übergangen was kann man tun um
tatsächlich zu helfen also nicht nur
ihnen sondern generell diesen kindern
werden die politik wie sie es ja gerade
beschrieben haben teilweise hilflos ist
teilweise nicht so richtig kann und sich
teilweise wegduckt was würden sie sagen
wie kann man als einzelner bürger
bürgerinnen effektiv unterstützen
naja ich hab das neue verglichen mit der
pionier generation die vor 70 jahren
unser land wieder aufgebaut hat wir
haben schon die gene dieser menschen in
uns weil das waren unsere großeltern und
wir wissen dass wir es besser machen
können unser land wird im moment auf der
einen seite solle solidarisch auf der
anderen seite egoistischer und wenn wir
alle ein bisschen mehr zusammenrücken
dann können wir uns tatsächlich
überlegen kaufe ich für ein mensch ein
der zur risikogruppe gehört rufe ich
meine nachbarin an und fragen sie ob ich
hier bei uns beim homeschooling helfen
kann
wir alle haben und nachbarn wir alle
haben menschen in dieser gesellschaft
die gesehen und wir können versuchen sie
zu unterstützen mit dem besten
möglichkeiten die wir haben auch wir
versuchen gerade mit online
ehrenamtlichen die kinder mit
hausaufgaben zu unterstützen versuchen
da ein neues konzept zu entwickeln um
auch viel weiter als unsere 27.000 in
deutschland zu gehen und vielleicht ein
flächendeckendes system zu schaffen wo
ehrenamtlichen auch virtuell mit den
kindern nachhilfe machen können ohne
dass das was kostet gerade für familien
die sich nach wenig leisten können das
heißt wenn jetzt jemand da draußen ist
der zukunft und dem oder der särge
langweilig ist derzeit diese menschen
gibt es ja auch die haben zu viel zeit
und können sich nicht im grunde ja
treffen draußen die können sich an sie
werden können sagen hier ich habe
expertise in dem und dem fach und ich
würde gern nachhilfe geben
gut dass ganz so einfach ist es nicht
natürlich steht bei uns auch der
kinderschutz im fokus unserer
ehrenamtlichen müssen auch ein
bewerbungsprozess durchlaufen bei wir
müssen unsere
in der schützen beim anderen wenden sich
natürlich auch leute die nur wir sind
aber noch in der regel natürlich
brauchen wir menschen die helfen dass es
den kindern in unserem land bessergeht
da braucht es viel initiative nicht nur
bei der arche
da gibt es viele andere organisationen
auch aber natürlich brauchen wir
flächendeckend auch ehrenamtliche die
das unterstützen damit den kindern und
unserem land bessergeht
also ein aufruf zur solidarität und
gegenseitiger hilfe von bentzel code im
grunde der arche in berlin
ich danke ihnen dass sie zeit hatten
heute für uns und euch auch vielen dank
fürs zu gucken und für das kommentieren
und fragen stellen wie immer es ist eine
schwierige zeit ich hoffe ihr hattet
weiter durch wir versuchen weiterhin
oder wir sind weiter für euch da mit den
themen die euch interessieren und
berühren und versuchen natürlich auch
weiter die aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten
jetzt nochmal erste wochenende und
hoffen dass nichts großartiges passiert
und ein gutes wochenende kommt bis dahin
macht es euch möglich dass dann und
tschüss